[Musique]
le plus grand fleuve sauvage d'europe
possède une maison dédiée à son histoire
et à sa nature près de 1000 km
représentés dans ces espaces sont à
découvrir grâce à des indices empreinte
de ragondin ou de héron à vous de
deviner
on est là pour créer un lien entre le
visiteur et le fleuve pour qu'ils aient
envie d'aller au contact du fleuve au
naturel ici c'est vraiment un coin
accroche on va donner quelques bribes
quelques petits trucs mais on va pas
tout dévoiler on soulève un petit peu le
rideau c'est tout pour qu'on puisse
jeter un oeil après il faut vraiment
aller sur le fleuve pour le voir en vrai
cette exposition permanente nous berce
dans l'histoire du fleuve durant la
renaissance
elle était au coeur du royaume de france
et servait à acheminer les pierres pour
les constructions des châteaux ou par
exemple recevoir les épices du monde
entier dans cette pièce on a des coffres
donc un peu partout dans la scénographie
en fait serment un lieu où on peut
toucher on peut fouiller ont pour ouvrir
les coffres et puis allez prendre les
objets qui sont à l'intérieur donc là
c'est une caisse une petite cassette de
mariniers de l'honneur de vinci pour
imager un peu le transport des idées et
puis sept grands hommes de science de
lettres qui était léonard de vinci à la
renaissance
toucher sentir et voir en d'être
imprégné pour aller découvrir soi-même
les beautés de la noire à 200 mètres à
peine de cette maison